Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we are still blazing
a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
Who wants to get naked
with the Shower Toga?
Narrator:
...by thinking big...
Simon: Zookies Cookies are
the most delicious treats
you have ever had.
...and chasing their dreams.
Woman: Introducing Goat Yoga.
[ Goat bleats ]
Oh, Lord.
What?
Narrator: And tonight,
Alli Webb, the founder
of the beauty powerhouse
the Drybar, joins the Tank.
From being in the hair industry
for 20 years,
I think there's
a good business here.
What are your sales?
‐$40,000 in sales.
Welcome to "Shark Tank."
We cannot keep products
on the shelf.
I'm willing to make you
an offer.
No!
It's like the first day
of school.
Kevin's the guy
who pulls your hair.
[ Chuckles ]
I believe that.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
are entrepreneurs
with special treats
you bake at home.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Justin Miller.
And I'm Tom Simon.
And we're from Raleigh,
North Carolina.
We're here today seeking
$50,000 in exchange
for 20% equity in our company,
Zookies Cookies.
Zookies.
Sharks, what you have
in front of you today
are the best bake‐at‐home
cookies on the market.
Our peanut butter cookies
are 100% plant‐based,
100% gluten‐free,
no added preservatives,
and no added sugar.
Zookies Cookies are
the easiest, most delicious,
home‐baked treats
you have ever had.
Trust us.
I had a fair share.
[ Chuckles ]
In front of you,
we've handed out
a few samples
for you guys to try,
and...bon appétit.
Cheers.
♪♪
So, Robert,
what do you think?
‐Oh, this is not ‐‐
‐It's not very good.
That's perfect.
You guys aren't exactly
our target demographic.
So, today,
we've brought with us
some of our happiest
customers...
Herjavec: I knew it.
Damn it!
I always get fooled!
...to show you how much they
love Zookies Cookies.
You do, Robert.
Send in Arthur, Benny,
and Charlie.
‐Aww.
‐[ Chuckles ]
It's like humans can eat it,
dogs can eat it.
‐Yeah.
‐Aww.
‐And you just did.
Yeah.
Welcome to "Shark Tank."
‐Oh, my God.
‐Damn it.
‐They are so cute.
‐Hi, buddy. Hi.
‐Hi.
‐Come to me.
[ Barks ]
[ Chuckles ]
Looks like your dog.
Well, they like it.
[ Laughter ]
Miller: That's right, Sharks.
What you just had in front
of you is the finest
and most delicious dog treat
on the market.
Zookies Cookies are so easy,
even Justin can make them.
Pour jar into the bowl,
add water,
bake for 30 minutes,
and that's it.
Bake?
Zookies Cookies
is a new breed of treat,
one that
you can feel great
about giving
your best fur friend.
So, Sharks, who's ready to mix,
bake, and tail shake?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐So many questions.
‐Just to be clear,
I have to cook the cookie
in my home
before I give it
to the dog?
That's right. This is really
about the experience
and the quality
of the product.
You could eat the treats
with your dog.
And we see that
with families ‐‐
Well...
‐No, you can't.
‐Nobody likes...
[ Laughter ]
Webb: I don't know.
That ‐‐ That ‐‐ Eh.
And I'd say ‐‐
Yeah, right.
Actually, the dog handlers,
if you guys ‐‐ We're good.
‐No.
‐Aww.
‐Bye.
‐Bye. Bye, guys.
‐No.
‐Bye, dogs.
If you had put
a dog in my lap,
I would definitely
have invested.
Oh.
Benny, come on back.
[ Laughter ]
Can I see the bottle?
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐Sure.
My brother, who is, like,
obsessed with his dog,
you can't believe
what he does for his dog.
You are not going to cook
cookies for your dog.
I kind of like baking, even
though I'm not very good at it.
I just kind of like
the process.
I'm getting it's a cleaner
treat for your dog.
‐Right, right.
‐But aren't there a lot of
treats that are already
made that do it, too?
‐Yes.
‐The beautiful thing
about this product is every
one of our ingredients
are stuff that you and I
would eat anyway.
There's no "dog" ingredients
in here.
When we were looking at all
of the great treat varieties
that are
on the shelves today,
the problem was, even the treats
that are branded as healthy
still had some problematic
preservatives or things in them.
And ‐‐
They don't say that.
They say they're healthy.
Of course.
So when you look at
our ingredients ‐‐
I think I'm worried
you're going to zero.
You know that?
The proof is in their sales.
Tell us about your sales.
Yeah. Yeah.
So far, we've done
just over $40,000 in sales
just over nine months.
‐And that's online or...
‐Online.
Uh, a very minimal amount
of retail testing...
‐Right.
‐...but ‐‐ but primarily online.
And how are you getting
your customers right now?
Direct targeting on Facebook,
uh, some Instagram,
and some Google.
O'Leary: What does this
cost me to buy?
So,
our jars are $9.99,
and we sell a three‐pack
for $24.99.
And it costs you
to make a jar...
‐Uh, just under $2.
‐Yeah.
‐Oh, a great margin.
‐So...
What are you hoping in a year
from now sales will be?
I think we can get into the
mid‐six figures a year in sales.
What we see happening is,
this is a very giftable product.
Over half of our sales
are gifts.
Cuban: Interesting.
What exactly do you think
you need help with?
We came here seeking
a strategic partner
more so than the capital
because we feel that there's
a big opportunity
with what we've created.
What we want to look at is
opportunities with big‐box
and also opportunities to expand
out on those social channels.
Give me an example.
Which pet big‐boxes?
When we look at ‐‐
at pet stores,
I think that there is
an opportunity,
although it's a pretty
saturated market.
I think this is also
perfect to sit
on health food stores for humans
to coincide with that.
Like a Whole Foods.
I think this is a really
nice component ‐‐
It doesn't tell me on
the packaging that I bake...
Herjavec: You think we can
get to Whole Foods?
...this is basically
a baking kit.
It doesn't tell me
what it is.
‐Yeah.
‐I mean, it's not clear to me
when I see this that ‐‐
Webb: No, but I think
you're right,
because it does look like,
what do you do with this?
‐Yeah.
I think you need to be ‐‐ If
there's one thing I've learned,
you know, is, from
our branding at Drybar...
‐Yeah.
‐...the importance of hierarchy.
I don't know what
to look at first.
So, if I say to you,
I don't think
it's gonna sell as‐is...
Simon: Mm‐hmm.
...are you willing to, like,
make some changes?
‐Yeah.
I mean, we've made changes
along the way
based on feedback
that we've seen.
We changed labels
a little bit.
Let me share with you guys
my thought.
It's a cute idea.
I see it more as a novelty
product that they'll do
fun with the kids
a few times a year,
but I don't see this
as something that
they're going to do every day,
even once a week.
And because of that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Herjavec: I think it's
an interesting idea.
I'm trying to figure out
whether I love it or not.
Here on "Shark Tank,"
we did invest
with a company
called PupBox,
a little box that
you get as a puppy.
And we sold that
for $2.5 million
within a short amount of time
to a big pet retailer.
People love their dogs.
I worry that
you're adding delay.
Like, I have to actually
bake it.
Oh, come on, Robert.
I don't think people are gonna
bake for their dogs.
I'm out.
♪♪
I think the pet space
is on fire.
I'm an investor
at Healthy Spot,
which is an upscale boutique
for dogs and cats and animals,
and it's growing
unbelievably.
People are obsessed
with their dogs,
and they will buy something
like this 100%.
It needs work, and I think
as long as you guys are open to,
you know, going back to
the drawing board a little bit
on a couple of things,
you know,
I think I can bring value
in helping you get
into certain retailers
and with gifting.
So I'm willing
to make you an offer.
Oh, my goodness.
Narrator: Two Sharks are out,
but Alli is interested
in Tom and Justin's dog biscuit
mix, Zookies Cookies.
You know, I think I can bring
value in helping you get
into certain retailers
and with gifting.
So I'm willing
to make you an offer.
Oh, my goodness.
50k for 30%.
‐Well.
‐That's an offer.
Here's my offer.
I have a lot
of gifting companies
that do millions of dollars
in sales.
Maybe there's a way to work
you guys into that portfolio.
I will offer you
the $50,000 for 33.3%
so I'm an equal dog partner.
Oh, my God.
A little bit more than Alli,
but I bring way more value.
But I don't even think
you like dogs.
I love dogs.
I love selling ‐‐
You don't ‐‐ You've ‐‐
‐He hates dogs.
‐He likes money.
Alli, you do not speak
Chihuahua. I do.
Do you guys have
any other partners?
I have a Chihuahua, and I want
to bake these for my dog.
I just like you guys.
I think the idea is really dumb,
but I like you guys.
You guys are great.
You see, I made you
a great offer.
I don't think
the idea is dumb.
And she will redo
your entire company.
I think there's some real value.
Let's ‐‐
You know, I'm ‐‐ This offer
isn't gonna be here forever.
‐Ooh.
‐Right.
I'd love to hear from Mark,
and I appreciate ‐‐
Yeah, guys.
Look, I heard the word "bake,"
and I didn't understand
the rest of it.
[ Laughs ]
‐If you want to talk tech...
‐You're like...
But I'm out.
[ Laughs ]
Okay.
Well, you have
two solid offers.
I would have
never thought that.
At least one solid offer.
Webb: One who has hair.
I want 3.3% more
because I'm worth it.
Oh. Oh!
In all seriousness,
I ‐‐
You know, I really see
an opportunity here.
♪♪
I think I very much appreciate
both of your offers.
Yeah.
Alli.
‐Whoo‐hoo!
‐Congrats, Alli.
So you have a deal?
We have a deal.
‐Congratulations.
‐Alli!
‐Mazel tov!
‐Whoo. Whoo.
I just want a puppy.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
And what a doozy of a deal.
Thank you all.
Thank you, guys.
‐Congrats.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐We really appreciate it.
‐Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
Congrats.
[ Both laugh ]
Simon: Having Alli as part
of this now will be great
because her products
are already well‐branded.
We've been talking about
repackaging and new
styles and new things,
and so having her as a partner
just feels fantastic.
Who is gonna bake
for their dog?
I'm telling you, people are ‐‐
Like, my ‐‐
You are not!
Yes, I am. So ‐‐
No, you're not.
Yes, I am.
‐Yeah, she will.
‐People will bake.
I will legit bake these
for my dog.
I'm very proud of you.
You were savage there. 30%.
‐I know. That is savagery.
‐That's so greedy.
Hey, they said "Yes."
Yeah, but they know that
she's going to help them.
Listen. I would not have done
this if I didn't believe in it.
Get a blow‐dry.
Get some cookie dough.
You wanted it, too.
♪♪
I was born in
Long island, New York,
but I was raised
in Boca Raton, Florida.
I had a great childhood.
I think I was
a little bit of a tomboy
until I discovered, like,
I was obsessed with my hair.
My parents were entrepreneurs.
They've had a clothing store
called Flip's.
And my dad was such a genius
because he set up chairs
for the husbands to sit at,
and he would bring them
the newspaper
and coffee and bagels.
If the husbands were
comfortable and content,
they would let their wives
shop longer,
which means they would
buy more clothes.
It was, like, my first lesson
in customer service.
After high school,
I was very lost.
I really didn't know
what I wanted to do,
but I always wanted to go
to beauty school,
and my parents were
a little like,
"Really? Is that really
what you want to do?"
But I enrolled in beauty school,
and the first day,
I fell in love.
I was like,
"These are my people.
This is what I want to do."
I moved to New York City,
and I worked for John Sahag,
one of the most famous salons
in the city.
It was amazing. It was such
a great experience.
While I was living
in New York,
I got married and moved
to Los Angeles
and became a stay‐at‐home mom.
I loved being a stay‐at‐home
mom, but after a few years,
I got the itch
to get back out there
and do something for myself.
All of my mommy friends always
asked me to blow out their hair,
so I thought, "Let me start
this little side hustle,"
and I realized there was
a huge hole in the marketplace.
We opened the first Drybar
in 2010,
and literally, from Day 1,
we were booked solid,
and it just never let up.
Drybar is a place where
you go for just blowouts.
We wash your hair,
and then we style it,
all while you're sitting
at a bar,
watching a chick flick,
working on your laptop,
and when you're done, we twirl
you around for the big reveal
when you get to see
your camera‐ready hair.
As women,
when our hair looks good,
we feel like we can
conquer the world.
We've grown Drybar
to over 100 locations.
We have a full product line
that's sold
in some major retailers
around the country.
We employ over 3,000 people.
I mean,
the business has expanded
well beyond my wildest dreams.
I feel like women and moms
in particular
make great business owners
because we're multitaskers.
I mean, women can handle a lot.
It's hard to balance,
but I think it's important
that women feel empowered,
that they can run
a great big business
and then still be a great mom
and just kind of
figure it out day by day.
I want to be a Shark because
I've had so many people
support me along the way that
I feel like I want to give back
and support other entrepreneurs.
I'm so excited to be able
to give some of the knowledge
and things that I've learned
building Drybar to somebody else
who's on the brink
of something really amazing.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a product line designed
for a specific hair type.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks. I'm Tim.
And I'm Kim.
We're high‐school sweethearts
from the South Side of Chicago.
And we're seeking
$400,000
for a 10% equity stake
in our company...
Both: CurlMix.
Sharks, women want to feel
confident and beautiful
with their naturally
curly hair.
But they need safe curly hair
products that deliver results.
Flaxseed gel is
the best organic ingredient
for styling curly hair.
Flaxseed gel gives you
moisturized,
voluminous curls
that last,
but you can't quite get it
in stores.
You have to make it
yourself.
Until now.
We've revolutionized the way
people get flaxseed gel
by creating the best pure
flaxseed gel on the market.
Here's how it works.
Our pure flaxseed gel
smoothes away frizz,
adds tons of shine,
and enhances their natural
curl pattern.
Diffuse your curls,
and voilà.
On the other side, we have a
completed section, fully dried.
As you can see, these curls
have volume and bounce.
The best part is,
they don't have to apply
any more product
for the rest of the week.
And it works
on all curl sizes ‐‐
wavy hair, curly hair,
super‐curly hair...
Wow! [ Laughs ]
...and kinky hair.
All right, Sharks.
Both: Who's ready to get
in the mix with CurlMix?
This will give you guys a closer
look at each of our products.
We've prepared a bundle.
Cool.
So we have...
Okay.
...sports‐car red
for you.
‐Ooh.
‐[ Laughs ]
For Lori,
we have a luscious lavender
'cause you're luscious.
Ooh.
For Kevin, we have
our hair‐growth bundle.
[ Laughter ]
We know you need it.
All right.
And for Alli,
we got you
our Drybar yellow
with our lemon creme
fragrance.
Wow.
Thank you so much.
And then, of course, Mark ‐‐
maverick blue.
Thanks, Tim.
Enjoy.
Herjavec: It's for people
with curly hair.
Yes.
Not to straighten it?
Correct.
Just to make it more curly?
To define their curls.
Absolutely.
However your hair looks
when it's wet and curly.
So, what would the hair look
like before and after?
So, this is their before.
Which side?
The le‐‐ The right side.
This side here.
[ Laughing ] Really?
‐You can't tell?
‐Right‐hand side.
So you'll see that
it's not really well‐defined.
And it looks ‐‐
How does it look different?
Webb: What?!
You're such a guy.
‐He's being funny.
‐That's such a guy ‐‐
‐No, he's not! No, he's not.
‐He's being serious.
‐I'm being serious.
It's true, because most guys
don't understand, like ‐‐
We don't pay attention
to the details.
‐Which [Scoffs]
‐Oh, wow.
You guys got to work
on that.
‐Sorry. This is the before.
‐Yeah.
And it's fluffy and ‐‐
And it ‐‐ Fluffy and frizzy,
and you see how the other side
is, like,
a more defined curl.
Like, you can actually
see the spiral?
‐Ohh.
‐Nice ringlets. Yes.
Webb: Yeah, it's so much
more defined, Robert.
You're like,
"Ooh, big whoop."
‐[ Laughing ] Okay.
‐Ooh.
But is this a big problem?
‐Yes.
‐Absolutely.
Hello. Drybar.
Yes. There is a problem.
[ Both laugh ]
There is a huge market for women
who want their natural curls.
I have naturally curly hair,
too, but not this curly.
So do I.
Did.
And if you want to go
with your natural curls,
you need something that makes
your hair look like pretty ‐‐
And so, what's the big deal
about flaxseed oil?
If you look online,
you'll find thousands of women
making their own
flaxseed gel at home.
Tim: If you're making it
at home,
it's ridiculously tough
to preserve.
It lasts two or three days
unless you freeze it.
And so we developed a method
to make flaxseed gel at scale.
We launched it in
a couple test batches.
We sold out
almost instantly,
and this is a month
after she gave birth.
Superwoman.
[ Greiner laughs ]
What are your sales?
Year to date,
we've done $400,000
in just these last
nine months.
‐Congratulations.
‐That's real money.
Are you guys beauticians?
I mean, what is your background?
We first got into the industry
five years ago.
We were
fresh out of college.
My wife hated her job,
so then she's a hustler.
And I was
a business major,
so I majored in Marketing
and Supply Chain Management.
Yes.
And so she wanted to pursue
entrepreneurship.
We didn't have the money
at the time,
so she booked me on
"Who Wants To Be A Millionaire?"
‐[ Laughs ]
‐No way.
I got on that show.
I won $100,000.
[ Cheering ]
[ Laughs ]
And then we used that
to invest in our first business.
‐Come on!
‐Yeah. It was ‐‐
‐That is hard. I just did that.
‐I know. That's amazing.
[ Laughs ]
What do you think you'll do
for the whole year in sales?
$1 million.
Yes.
‐So we're on track to do
a million in sales.
‐$1 million?
‐And will you be profitable?
‐Wow.
Yes, by the end
of the year.
We'll be cash‐flow positive
in one month.
Wow.
In two months,
we'll be profitable.
And we're projecting $180,000
in profits this year.
Tim, you never told me
what it costs.
What does it sell for?
About $25.
The lowest bottle
is $25 to $28.
And what does it cost you
to make it?
So, it costs about $3 to make
a regular bottle of gel.
So you sell for $25,
you make it for $3.
Yes.
I love you so much.
And with an investment,
we can cut that in half.
[ Laughs ]
And what do you need
the money for?
What are you gonna do
with the $400,000?
The main issue we have now
is we cannot keep products
on the shelves.
Yeah.
So we need ‐‐
Don't you hate
when that happens?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐It is. I ‐‐
That's actually called
a champagne problem.
Every week, my goal is
to get off back order.
So right away, we need
to invest in inventory.
And we can also invest
in new equipment
'cause we can do this
even bigger.
We're making 700
in a batch.
With new equipment,
we can double, 10x that.
Webb: How are you gonna get
market share?
Mm‐hmm.
I mean, I started
a product line myself that ‐‐
there's a million
dry shampoos out there.
Right.
I believe ours is the best,
and there's reasons for that.
Of course.
But, like, what is it
for you guys
that makes yours different
and unique?
Our main competitor
is actually DevaCurl.
And how big are they?
Um...
Um, $100 million a year.
‐Maybe ‐‐ Maybe $200 million.
‐Easy.
‐Yeah. Easy.
‐Robert, easy.
Wow.
Cuban: Guys, I'm gonna
simplify it.
I have no clue
what you're talking about.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Understood.
Thank you very much.
So, I love this business
because the margins are crazy,
but there's a reason
for that.
‐Yeah.
‐Mm‐hmm.
It's brutally competitive,
and you need that margin
to buy the brand
and the marketing.
Are you gonna need
a massive push
in the market
to buy brand?
Mm‐hmm.
Well, not only that. You need
massive infrastructure, too.
Right.
Because I know personally
how hard it is
to start a product line.
Now we have, like,
a team of, like,
I don't know,
30 people,
that if you really want
to compete with the big guys...
Yeah.
...the DevaCurls of the world,
like, you have to put
a lot of infrastructure
in place,
and frankly, $400,000 ‐‐
‐Yeah, see, I ‐‐ I ‐‐
‐It's not gonna do it.
This is one of the few
investments that I think,
if I give you $400,000,
you're definitely gonna grow
and you're gonna
get bigger.
Mm‐hmm.
What I worry about is,
the car goes faster
and then hits a wall.
‐Yeah.
‐Mm.
And so,
for those other brands,
a lot of them think
retail first,
and that's not
our strategy.
Our strategy is
to stay online right now
because our margins
are so big.
Well, you don't have
any other choice
because you're not gonna get
any retail space.
That's a point.
The problem with
high‐margin products
is the guys
that own that space
protect it
as if they're warriors.
Mm‐hmm.
They don't give up
one single inch.
When they get competition ‐‐
But could you get
an inch out of them?
Well, they ‐‐ they buy their
space. They maintain.
He has no hair.
You don't have the power?
You have the power to do it.
Yes.
I know you do.
There's no way
this business is worth
$4 million right now.
There's nothing proprietary
about taking flaxseed
and boiling it,
so if this works
and you get to
$50 million in sales,
some guy that's doing
$2 billion is gonna say,
"Okay, boil some flaxseed.
Let's crush the CurlMix
cockroaches."
But we would obtain
extra money by then.
Maybe.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
We appreciate that.
I am impressed that, without
being chemists or whatever,
you know, you went in
and you figured out
this extraction process.
I just don't know about
this space well enough
to know
how to compete up against
those major, major brands.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
We appreciate the kind words.
Thank you so much.
So, I think you guys
are amazing.
Like, you have such,
like, charisma,
and I feel like you could
sell ice to an Eskimo.
I ‐‐ I mean, I really ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
I try.
You ‐‐ I mean,
you guys are good.
I think there's
a good business here,
and I know from being in
the hair industry for 20 years
that this is a need,
unequivocally.
Yes.
There is a need for
this kind of product,
which maybe I'll put some
flaxseeds in stuff now.
Just kidding.
‐Oh, shame on you.
Shame on you.
‐Uh‐oh.
‐Flaxseed.
‐You are a savage.
I'm a Shark!
I can't believe it.
Listen, I'm not stealing
anything. I promise.
Oh, my goodness.
I'm not in
the curly hair business.
I'm in the business
of making curly hair straight.
But, like Lori said,
you have a lot of competition
with a lot more infrastructure
and more money behind them.
Mm‐hmm.
I think the space might
be too crowded,
so I'm out.
Yes.
O'Leary:
But it's not over yet.
Robert, who has problems
with his hair all the time ‐‐
Herjavec: All right, you
know, I was on the fence.
Do you know what kind of
tipped me over?
What?
The queen of hair.
Ah.
I didn't know if there was
a need, but there's a need.
Yeah.
But I haven't invested
in this space.
It's very risky to me,
so I have to make you
a Sharky offer, which ‐‐
that's why I'm a Shark.
Hmm.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Robert is Tim and Kim's
last chance
to make a deal for their
hair gel company, CurlMix.
I haven't invested
in the space.
It's very risky to me,
so I have to make you
a Sharky offer, which...
Let's hear it.
...that's why I'm a Shark.
I will give you
the $400,000...
I hear
a flaxseed royalty!
[ Laughter ]
No, no, no.
I don't want a royalty.
I'll do it for 20%.
Oh, that's nothing.
‐That's a good offer.
‐You should take that deal.
Yes.
I expected a lot worse
than that, guys.
Would you consider 15%?
I would not.
Sharky deal.
‐I would not.
‐It's a good offer, though,
because that money
will really help you.
I'm ‐‐ I'm ‐‐
So, Robert, um,
I understand that you see
that there's risk
in the business.
We appreciate that.
I do.
We are going to grow,
but we also see ourselves
as kind of the next
billion‐dollar beauty brand.
Yeah.
We aren't just going
to stay in flaxseed.
We aren't just gonna stay
in curly hair.
You guys
will figure it out.
I mean, that's what great
entrepreneurs do, is they pivot.
Mm‐hmm.
But it's risky for me
as an investor today, right?
Like, I'm buying
part of the future,
but I ‐‐ I'm buying
what I see today.
Well, when we came up
with our valuation,
we did last month's sales
and we multiplied it by 12.
Like, if we didn't
grow at all,
we would make $115,000
for the next 12 months.
Kim...
So we actually ended up with
a $6.9 million valuation,
but we brought it down
to $4 million.
'Cause we really
wanted a Shark.
Oh. Hey, I can work
a spreadsheet, too.
We'll need a lot of money,
so we will probably
have to raise again.
Yes, which is why
I need 20% today.
Greiner: And you're
getting a Shark.
♪♪
$400,000 for 20%.
I'm not gonna change that.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪
Sorry, Robert.
‐Oh!
‐[ Gasps ]
‐No!
‐Really?!
‐We can‐‐ We cannot take that.
‐I respect that.
‐Good for you.
‐Wow.
‐I have to say...
‐I didn't see that coming.
‐...I'm out. Thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐We appreciate all the offers.
You know what?
That's confidence.
Congrats for
sticking to your guts.
Wow, how about that?
Webb: I can't believe
they didn't take it.
‐I can't, either.
‐I can't believe that, either.
Kim: CurlMix is going to have
a massive launch in retail
and be the next billion‐dollar
hair‐care company.
The Sharks absolutely missed out
on a huge deal.
We could've 10x'd their money
in a year,
could've 100x'd their money
in two years,
and they really,
really are gonna hate
missing out on that deal.
Why didn't Alli do it?
What? Who? Alli?
Why didn't you
do this deal?
I am in the business
of turning curly straight.
What you're really saying is,
you hate women with curly hair.
It's the opposite.
Oh, my God, no.
That's what I heard.
The truth is,
you can do it yourself
for less than $400,000.
Admit the truth.
That's not ‐‐
It'll set yourself free.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations, "Shark Tank,"
on a decade of dreams
from the Alice's Table team.
Thank you for bringing us
all together.
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a twist
to an ancient practice.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Rachael Phillips.
And I'm Trey Kitchen.
And today we're seeking $50,000
for 15% of our company.
Sharks, we all know
the benefits of practicing yoga,
like increased strength,
flexibility, and mindfulness.
But sometimes that downward dog
gets downright boring.
And that's why we created
our company.
[ Chuckles ]
Introducing
GOGA Goat Yoga.
[ Goat bleats ]
Oh!
Aww!
They're so cute!
[ Goats bleating ]
Baa!
[ Goat bleats ]
Oh, my God.
I want to touch one.
Hi, guys.
GOGA Goat Yoga
is exactly like yoga,
but with baby goats.
What?
Now, I'm sure you're asking
yourselves, "Why goats?"
Yes. Why goats?
Goats naturally like
to play King of the Hill,
so while you're in
that downward dog ‐‐ boom ‐‐
a goat jumps on your back.
[ Goat bleating ]
They also enjoy snuggling up
on yogis' mats
once they get tired.
Or sometimes they'll
come up and give you
a nice little head bump
to say, "Keep going."
GOGA is great for team building,
bachelorette parties,
or just a fun, relaxing workout
after a long week.
Now, who wants to grab a mat
and come try GOGA?
‐Me!
‐Yes!
‐Come on.
‐For sure!
‐Ohh.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐You guys want to say hi?
‐I want to hold one.
Okay, grab a mat.
We're gonna face this way.
Start on your hands and knees
in a tabletop pose.
‐Tabletop.
‐Okay, you can set him down.
Yep.
[ Goat bleats ]
Hey.
Here's your buddy.
[ Laughs ]
So, you want to have a nice,
strong back in this pose
so that the goats have
a stable surface.
Is there a goat on my back?
‐There sure is.
‐Oh!
The goat bit me!
[ Laughs ]
Try to come up
into a plank pose.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
That's good, Robert.
If you can, push up into
a downward‐facing dog.
There you go.
How does it feel?
There's a goat on my back.
[ Laughter ]
That's what it feels like.
We want to do a couple
of standing poses,
if you're up for it.
So, grab a little goat.
‐Give me the goat.
‐Here's Scarlet.
See if you can balance
on your left foot
and then just bring your
right foot into a tree pose.
So, um...
‐Good, Robert.
‐That works, too.
Now take some nice
deep breaths
while you're holding
this little...
All right,
I think we get it.
‐This is so much fun.
‐It's Goat Yoga.
‐Good job.
‐I'm taking my goat.
‐Yeah, here we go.
‐You can take this one.
All right.
‐I love this little goat.
‐Let the goat go, Lori.
Run free, young goat.
Run free!
‐Interesting concept.
‐Is this a real thing?
Kitchen: Yeah, we've been doing
it for about a year now.
We started right after
Hurricane Harvey. Uh...
Why? 'Cause you had
spare goats?
Yeah.
It was a fundraiser.
We had seen YouTube videos
of it, and we thought,
"Why not bring this
to Austin
to raise money
for Hurricane Harvey?"
His mother raises goats
and sells them as pets.
So, what is the benefit?
Why do you want a goat
standing on you?
[ Goat bleating ]
Animals naturally bring you
to the present,
and they are
very therapeutic.
So a lot of the times, we have
people come to our classes
and say, "This is exactly
what I needed
after a stressful week,"
or, "I just had
a death in the family,
and this really helped me
cope with that."
So, a little story
for you, here.
‐Oh, Lord.
‐Oh, no!
There's a supplementary
income stream available.
Let me explain it.
Oh, no.
I lived on the island of Cyprus
when I was young.
There's a mountain range
on Cyprus
called the Troodos Mountains,
and it's a tradition
for the Cypriot people
to go up on Sunday
up into the mountains
and take a baby goat,
slaughter it,
and barbecue it.
And I got to
tell you something.
Greiner: Oh, Kevin!
Of all of the things
I've eaten on barbecue,
nothing is as good as goat.
These goats are not a good breed
for meat or for milk.
Are you sure?
They're strictly for pets.
Positive.
Okay, so, guys, how often
do you teach classes?
What do you charge?
Do you have a space
that you're doing this in?
Like, where do you
keep the goats?
We do. Well, we started at
the top of the parking garage
where I lived
in downtown Austin.
We now have one studio
that's sort of
more of a temporary thing.
We, um, use it in exchange
for the foot traffic
that we bring in to the
other retailers in the area,
and then we also just secured
our second location.
Who's the yoga instructor?
We hire them.
Oh, you guys don't do it.
‐No.
‐No, we hire instructors.
The whole goat thing ‐‐
like, I really love, like,
Pygmy goats ‐‐ so cute ‐‐
but at some point,
do you feel that
that wears off?
Absolutely.
So, we're already going into
now what we call phase 2.
We're gonna do full‐time yoga
90% of the time,
and then we'll do the Goat Yoga
still every other weekend.
How much does it cost
to take a class?
Is it a different price
when there's a goat involved?
A regular yoga class is
typically from $20 to $25.
Goat Yoga
is $30 a person.
We also do a lot
of private events,
so for those, we charge
$40 a person.
I get it, because I think
animals really bring out
the best in people...
Sure.
...but it feels
very gimmicky.
It is
somewhat of a novelty.
People love to do it,
but a lot of those people
who come have never
done yoga before,
and so it's a great
introduction to them.
It's getting them
in the door.
They come to our studio,
the goats are the ice breaker,
then they want to sign up
for a membership.
Herjavec: Trey, do you have
any revenue?
Like, what are your sales?
Yeah. This year,
we've done $250,000.
Good for you.
And how much of it comes
from just the normal yoga?
We don't do
any regular yoga yet.
No, we just...
No, we've done
100% Goat Yoga.
So for a year ‐‐
All that money was just
in Goat Yoga?
Yes.                   Yeah.
But that's awesome, guys.
You know what?
And that's with no AC,
no electricity, no bathrooms.
‐Wow.
‐Do you have competition?
It's popping up
all over the country now.
We have one competitor
in Austin.
What makes
your business different
than any of the other ones?
So, one thing is
our partnership
with Trey's mom, Roxie,
who gives us a constant supply
of baby goats.
The best goats.
A lot of people are doing it
with large goats,
so you've got a 100‐pound goat
on your back with big horns.
They are.
We only use goats
that are this size.
That sounds scary.
Trey: We use only baby goats.
I definitely don't want
a goat with horns.
See, that would be cool.
They have over 200 goats.
My wife opened up a fitness
studio about a year ago.
It is a brutally hard
business.
The minute you get
dedicated office space,
your rent goes up,
you have fixed costs.
You've got to start
cycling more classes.
It feels a little gimmicky
to me,
because, really,
it's a yoga studio
that every now and then
has a goat.
Cuban: Right.
I can't get there with you.
I'm out.
So, a couple things
to your scaling ‐‐
a lot of the other Goat Yogas
are not doing it near,
like,
the downtown area.
We're bringing the goats
into downtown ‐‐
But that's not even really
the issue, right?
It's not like 80% of yoga,
uh, practitioners
are going to start doing
Goat Yoga.
I would suggest you keep it
on the rooftop,
because you can start
building your yoga studio
and then
maybe integrate in.
But it's a niche market,
and while you might be able
to open more than one,
it ‐‐ then you're just
a yoga studio that
happens to have one angle,
and I don't see it as
an investable business,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐I love this idea.
It's different and inventive,
but, for me, with Drybar,
I've been a professional
hairstylist for 20 years,
and I feel like that gave me
a very unique position
because we have
a ton of copycats
and a ton of competition.
A lot of those ‐‐
those entrepreneurs
aren't hairstylists,
so they don't understand
the way the hair business
works.
Yeah.
So what makes me nervous
is the fact that, like,
you're not a yoga instructor.
A lot of girls I know
take yoga very seriously,
so I think you want to know
that it's coming from someone
who's, like,
obsessed with yoga.
It just doesn't feel right
to me, so I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
There's tons
of yoga studios,
and you've taken something
and made yourselves stand out.
I like the angle of it.
I think it's really clever
and cute,
but I don't feel this is
the right business for me.
Good luck,
but, unfortunately, I'm out.
Thank you.
But, Lori,
will you buy a goat?
You know, one day,
I might get a Pygmy goat.
Mom, you might be able
to make it.
Mom, do you ship?
‐Ship a goat.
‐She ships!
‐I'll tell you what.
I'll buy the goat.
You won't be seeing
that goat anymore.
No, don't sell to him.
No, we're not
selling goats to you.
Look, guys, I'd rather eat goat
than put it in my portfolio.
I'm out.
‐All right.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Good luck.
‐Come on, girls.
‐Come on. Let's go.
Oh, my God.
I truly would want one.
[ Imitates
goat bleat ]
[ Goat bleats ]
The little goats
are much more tender,
and it's all protein,
no fat.
We should be whacking
those guys.
There should be
no goats alive.
That's so horrible.
Alli, you could make
goat shampoo
and sell it in the store.
Cuban: Right?
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a simple
solution for a dirty problem.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Kressa,
and I am the inventor
of the Shower Toga.
I am here to offer
33% equity in my company
in exchange for $80,000.
Here to help me introduce
my product is my son, Conner,
my daughter, Layla,
and my wonderful husband,
otherwise known
as the Dirty Fairy.
Sharks, my family loves
to do obstacle‐course races.
You may know them better
as mud runs,
but do not make the mistake
of not thinking
that it's
a very serious sport.
When we are racing,
we are running and crawling
through mud, salt water,
sand, pond scum,
and then when we're finished,
maybe they give us
a group changing tent
and a water‐hose station,
but it's not private,
and you cannot get clean
with your workout clothes on.
I looked everywhere
for a solution.
There was nothing,
and that's why I invented...
the Shower Toga!
‐Ta‐da!
The Shower Toga is
the absolute only solution
for getting dirty in public,
undressing your clothes...
Ah.
...rinsing off, getting
dried off, and re‐dressed.
The Shower Toga is
for surfers, hikers,
bikers, music festivals.
So, who wants to
get naked in public
with the Shower Toga?
The Dirty Fairy
is super pumped
about handing samples
out to you guys.
Thank you.
I want to go
do mud racing now.
I didn't know
that was a thing.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Fairy.
Okay, so now,
as you can see,
Layla and Conner are fresh
and clean, but, hey,
Conner's going to pick up
a hot date.
Do you really think
he wants
all of his muddy crap
in his car?
No.
She's gonna think
he's a slob, right?
Not now, because his Shower Toga
acts as a duffel bag.
That's such a good idea!
‐So...
‐That is a good idea.
‐Yes!
Is it a good idea?
Have you sold any?
Yes,
it's a great idea, Mom.
I have! I have.
I've sold $80,000 worth.
That's not bad.
How ‐‐ What ‐‐
‐How long a period of time?
‐Yeah, how long?
Um, I ‐‐
really, since November.
Where and how
did you sell that?
We ‐‐ Like I said,
we do obstacle‐course races
all over the world.
So you took these to
obstacle‐course races?
I did.
I started selling them
from our rolling‐cart
bucket thing.
Okay.
What did you do
before this?
I ‐‐
It's kind of a strange ‐‐
I've always been
an entrepreneur.
We used ‐‐
We wouldn't expect anything
strange from you guys.
Never.
No.
We do strange. We own that
Hula‐Hoop space of strange.
I love that space.
Um, we've always been
entrepreneurs.
We actually had a home‐building
business in Atlanta,
and the market tanked.
Um, I used to show horses,
and so, for the last 10 years,
I've been a broker
for high‐end sport horses.
What are you
selling it for?
My retail price is $34.95.
That's all?
My wholesale is $16.
And what does it cost you
to make one?
$2.85.
‐Yeah, baby!
‐Whoa!
‐I love the margin!
Greiner: So, you figured this
whole thing out yourself.
Oh, boy, did I.
Yes, I don't sleep.
How did you do that?
Kressa, isn't your competition
a garbage bag?
Herjavec: Kevin.
Oh, my gosh. That's like
saying that a balloon
is the same thing
as a condom.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, but if you ‐‐
if you go ‐‐
Why doesn't a garbage bag
do the same thing?
First of all, a garbage bag ‐‐
you could step into it.
It's gonna tear.
You need space for your ‐‐
Not the ones
that hold leaves.
They're, like, a buck,
2 bucks each.
No. I'm gonna
answer your question.
Well, they use garbage bags
at concerts.
I go to them.
People wear them.
Let her answer.
First of all, the ‐‐ the side
openings on the Shower Toga
have also what's called
a welt pocket, okay,
and the reason for this
is because
if you just have slits on
the side, you're gapping.
You gap and bend over...
And you can see stuff!
Right, yes.
Thousands more people are using
garbage bags than this.
Kevin, to your point,
a garbage bag's gonna leak.
And in ‐‐ Exactly!
The water's gonna
pour into it.
You're gonna get
completely wet.
No, it doesn't.
Well, yes, 'cause the
drawstring's not gonna stay dry.
Webb: But the other thing is,
did you notice?
I feel like men can do it
and wrap it around their waist
and pull their pants down
easily, but girls ‐‐
Like, she had, like,
a sports bra on.
Right. And so,
here's the top here.
O'Leary: I just ‐‐
Look, I don't want
to take any air
out of the
Shower Toga balloon,
but it works the same way,
costs 2 bucks.
Is your idea that the races
would sell them
or give them out?
Yes.
We actually just got
a PO from one of the largest ‐‐
the fastest‐growing
race companies.
How many did they order?
How big was the order?
Uh, 1,000 units.
So, have you sold it to
any s‐‐ anybody besides
surfers or racers?
I actually had somebody
that e‐mailed me.
She was a caregiver
for the elderly,
and she bought it...
Yeah.
...because her patients
didn't want
to get undressed
in front of her.
O'Leary: Oh.
Granny in a plastic bag?
Retirement community.
You're still on
the plastic‐bag thing.
It's more dignity.
‐Yeah.
‐It's not a plastic bag.
O'Leary:
I love your energy.
You ‐‐ You are
really aggressive.
It's fantastic.
Yeah, you are amazing.
But I don't like to invest
in products
where the competition's
a garbage bag
that costs 99 cents, okay?
[ Laughter ]
So, that's not exciting
for me. So, look.
You do a garbage bag.
I wish you the best, but there's
no way I'm doing this deal.
I'm out.
You know what? I'm gonna ‐‐
I'm gonna do you a favor.
Cuban: Do him a favor.
I'm gonna give you
30 seconds to ‐‐
to ‐‐ to ‐‐ you just sit,
and you think for 30 seconds.
30 seconds, man.
29...
Cuban: Kressa,
have you tried
to sell online at all?
We ‐‐ I mean, we sell
a lot through our website.
But your website we ‐‐
But our Amazon
just started recently.
And it's tougher, isn't it?
It is a lot tougher, yeah.
I quit my job in April.
I bought a truck,
and we rented out our house,
took them
to obstacle‐course races,
and we sell them
from our fifth wheel.
What's a fifth wheel?
It's like
a big huge trailer,
and we live
in the fifth wheel.
Greiner: So, then
you travel around...
Yeah.
In the trailer.
...and you go from
show to show to show...
Right. Exactly.
...and that's your life.
You are so passionate
about this.
Yes.
I mean, what does this business
mean to you personally?
[ Sniffles ]
[ Laughing ] Crap.
[ Laughs ]
Sorry.
[ Sniffles ]
[ Voice breaking ]
Five years ago,
I, um, got breast cancer
[sniffles]
and I just needed
something to, like,
bury myself into
that made me not think,
'cause I think all the time.
It's just all I do.
I didn't plan on ‐‐
I imported horses,
for crying out loud.
Like, a retail product?
But it ‐‐ it's just evolved
so organically,
and it's actually helped
a ton of people,
and I don't mean,
like, it saved the world.
That's not my point.
My point is,
when you're done doing
whatever it is you're doing,
you can go to dinner.
You go to the beach, you don't
have to drive 30 minutes
back to your beach house.
Like, you're clean.
I mean, it's just ‐‐
No, I get that.
I mean, listen,
I feel like that's ‐‐
I said the exact same thing
when I started Drybar.
We're not
changing the world.
Right.
But it turns out we are,
and I always say that ‐‐
Now I'm gonna cry.
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's like,
we're making women feel
really good about themselves.
Right.
And so ‐‐ Ugh.
I can relate.
[ Laughing ]
What is wrong with me?
There is a part to this
that I haven't gone into
that I really want to do,
and that is disaster relief,
and I actually have
a contact at FEMA,
and the statistics say most of
the deaths from disaster relief
are not from
the actual disaster.
They're from hygiene
and infection afterwards.
I'm from Houston originally.
During the hurricane,
I had so many friends out there.
They were in their same clothes
for days.
Right.
Kressa, I love it.
‐What are you doing, Robert?
‐I think you're full of energy.
I think you have
an amazing family.
I think it's gonna
be challenging,
but if anybody is ever gonna
make a business out of this...
[ Laughs ]
...it's gonna be you.
But as an investment,
I'm not there.
I'm out.
I'm gonna give you
the same offer.
All right.
I'll give you 30 seconds.
His time's up.
Is his 30 seconds over?
‐It's gone.
‐I'm still out.
Um, I ‐‐ Listen,
I don't see why you need
to take on an investor.
You make a great margin.
Mm‐hmm.
You're out there selling it.
You're pounding down doors.
Um, not often do I say it,
but in this circumstance,
I wouldn't take on
an investor.
I wouldn't want to invest in
your company for those reasons,
and so I'm out.
You're gonna get
a time‐out.
‐Am I gonna get a time‐out?
‐No.
Kressa, I think you're
the perfect entrepreneur.
Thank you.
You took the idea,
you put in the work
to turn it into a product.
Yes.
Now, in terms
of selling it,
I think the name
needs to change.
It's got to be so that when
someone goes onto Amazon
or anyplace else online
that's going to sell this,
they know exactly
what you're doing.
It's like, yeah, immediate.
So, Alli and I love it.
[ Laughs ]
We do, and you remind me
of myself.
I feel like you're
a very strong entrepreneur.
You're clearly not
taking "No" for an answer.
You're not afraid
to stand up to these guys.
Like, I feel like ‐‐
and put them in their place.
I'm not afraid of them.
I mean, but I think that
that's a really important thing
for women in business,
because you have to be able to,
like, sit in a room
full of men
who are telling you
your idea's not good and say,
"No,
it actually is good,"
and I think that
you have this fire.
So Mark and I are gonna
make you an offer.
Okay. Um...
$80,000 from the two of us,
but we need 40%
since you're getting
two for one.
‐[ Sighs ]
‐Wow.
They're not so nice now.
[ Chuckles ]
Remember about garbage bags.
They're free.
Oh, man.
‐You're out, remember?
‐Forget him, Kressa.
‐Don't listen to him.
‐That's right.
‐I'd take that offer.
Yeah, just don't
focus on them.
Okay.
I'm just ‐‐ You have no idea
how honored I am.
Like, just to be here...
So say "Yes."
I know I'm supposed to
negotiate, but I get two of you.
How do I negotiate
for that?
[ Voice breaking ]
You've got a deal.
Whoo!
[ Cheering ]
Greiner: Yay.
Aww.
Congratulations.
It's a garbage bag.
All that fairy dust
got sprinkled down.
‐Guys, thank you. Thank you.
‐Congratulations.
Even you, thank you.
Ahh!
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Ahh! [ Laughs ]
For everything I've given up,
I feel vindicated because they
believed in me and my product,
and that means more to me
than anything else.
‐I love her.
‐Love her.
She's amazing.
She's, like, so infectious.
Yes. Amazing.
Okay, now that she's gone,
you realize you bought
a garbage bag
with a string on it.
Oh!
You know what? Step in here.
I'm gonna pull a Houdini.
♪♪